はい
今日は拾ってゆチューバー
肇社長ですあのねぇ
清水行きいますよ深さに見えとかありませんから
正直に言ってん
忙しいです大学卒論カードゲームテレビゲームスマホゲーム
youtube 俺にはやらないことがタックスワーッってねもう本当にねあの像何時
にそのシーンですよ一日という音24時間で構成されてまして人はその24時間以内で
何ができるかということはつまりしか言わなきゃいけないんだがしかし僕はその24
時間では足りないくらいの
なことをやりいけないんですよね僕の生活いつももうめちゃくちゃです24時間という
もの一つの時間からくね1周半から大型字幕が床れって僕のせいが訂正はめちゃくちゃ
で昼夜逆転してるんです今角7をなんかその布団に行く時がなんか朝とか起きた嫁だっ
たとかすごい口を寝るか心が可能性滝があるんですよ
うん授業とかの予定もあるし
朝に出たのにすぐ起きなきゃいけないとか言って僕はもう睡眠不足の時も多い大
親だろ
はい草ず言ってしまいます中田大智頭おかしいこんな僕のですけども
こんな僕にでもないものが届きましたこちらです
魚を持って両地裁定めちょっと疲労困憊しているこの僕にレベルベントンさんから
こんなものが届きました
えっ凄さってまずクルーズ枕ついてるのマークが付いてる凄くこれもついての替え歌だ
ねクッションというものでございますこちら何がすごいかといいますとまずビーズ
クッションが付いてるプースーのクッションとこの日
ビーズクッション合体しているという直子 naoko ズレるわけですよ
まあ
はああそいつは寝ればよりマキュラータおいて言ってるぞ
邪魔キャラ向こうさんが好んでるってことじゃんファンネルや
これはやばいサーフらがな人はダメにすればこれは果たしてをダメにするでございが服
じゃ素材の方なんですけども
リバーシブルってこちらこの辛さだけ夏ところさぁゲーム放っ
繰り返すとこちらから
普段とには長いであろうもふもふのねボブ後彼の記事のほうがあります
これだけでも僕はもう満足ですよ俺ねベッドに行くのは選挙めんどくさいんですこれで
クッションとしても使えますし
パソコンとのもんねスマホともできるし不死鳥が上がる
クッシュねさてたら通ずるズってこっちのクッションとこのビーズクッション合体し
てるってもう恋の者がずれ橇いく言葉
ないんですよよくこの2つを買ったんですよ本当だっけ究極の幸せだます
これはイースツアーででね俺はね気づいてしまったんだ
ここにあるこの先真っ暗マックやつってたんですけどファンならー
じゃあこんなをあけると中ではなんとなーんと
もう吸ってるわけですよチャックがついてるんですけども
このジャックを喚起等できたつ抜けましたーこっちないじゃう人そういうボスよりも
そういうことですよ
言えばまあそういうことじゃんこのままもうおやしみ車
このままでレバー血腫
じゃないでしょこれ今グっしょんはここまで進化したでございますってこの第二の
ビーズクッションだけはもうこれで俺もね満足してたさらにそれに通常のグっしょんが
ついてさ
日本で袋をついてるんでも
まま寝れるって訳ですね卒論とか動画編集
ああああってああ
なくたらそのままホームで増えるわけですよ
刺さったん
ホンダね言い方でもうあのーネタじゃない方で本当におすすめですうたたねクッション
どんなをネイルっていうのは何よりの幸せですから cb も大事なんですけどもね
まあより良いその睡眠の質を上げるためにね柔らかいビーズクッション
柔らかいクッションそして柔らかい寝袋の算定生徒が一つになっている
うたたねクッション
もし熱波のクッションで他のスバルだけじゃなくてクッションでその寝ちまいたいと
傾いから毛布が欲しいとかそういうちょっと欲張りな方は是非見た舐めクッションお
すすめですじゃあおやすみなさい
によっていた
ガー
ん